today i'm spilling the tea on a topic i
know that many of you are interested in
and this is salaries at tier one
consulting firm like mckinsey bcg or
bain so welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel firm learning
my name is jaime and as you know on my
channel i want to help you to become
successful
in the first years of your career and
part of that is for sure also
understanding
what the salaries are that you could
potentially be earning
over the first years of your career and
i want to help you with that with this
video
and specifically i will address this in
the following way so we'll start with
providing some general remarks and
qualifications
that are just important to understand
the numbers better that i will now share
with you in a moment
and then i will go over some key roles
key positions in the career track in the
t1 consulting firm
this is going to be the business analyst
role the associate role
the project lead role and the partner
role and i will discuss for each of
these
roads what your salary expectations can
be
if you work in such a tier one firm so
let's indeed start with these
qualifications and what's indeed
important to me here
is that of course in this video i will
now not share
specific numbers of any specific
consulting firm so you know that i had a
past at mckinsey
but i will now not specifically talk
about mckinsey but also consider friends
working at companies like boston
consulting or bain
and take all their experiences to
provide you here a rough overview of how
these consulting expectations in tier 1
firms look like
next important point is that salaries
differ significantly country by country
region by region the salaries in germany
might be significantly different from
the salaries in let's say spain
or also uk or the us so have this in
mind in this video we specifically focus
on the situation in germany
because i know that this is a region
that many of you are familiar with and i
trust that this
will be informative for people in other
regions as well but do your research for
your region and if you're wondering well
how shall i do this how shall i find
this information for my country
i created a course on salary
negotiations together with a good friend
of mine who is also former consultant i
will link this course below in the video
description
and there's also full module on the
topic of salary research such as this
will contain some interesting insights
last but not least i will now talk about
base salary so the base salaries that
you would pretty much get
fixed independent of your performance on
top of that most firms have also bonus
that they're offered to you and this is
usually up to 20
or so so if you're rated in the highest
performance category
this is what you can expect of course
most people will not get the highest
rating inside a performance rating which
is about average or slightly above
average
you can expect to get a bonus which will
roughly be 10
of your base salary so this is what you
should then add on top
to the numbers that i will mention to
you and then of course if you look at
the full compensation package
most firms also offer something like a
company car that you will get even as a
junior consultant and then there are
other benefits like insurances or
additional travel allowances that will
be provided to you
which you should add on top of this base
salary that we will be discussing right
now so let's get into it and discuss the
individual roads in detail
and while i will now also provide a
little characterization of the roads if
you really no idea
how this works what the roads the
responsibilities of these different
positions exactly are
i created a full video on that was
called how a career in consulting looks
like
and i will link it somewhere above here
so check this out if this is all new to
you and you really want to understand a
bit better
how the whole career path in consulting
looks like so the first role i want to
talk about is the business analyst role
and how exactly these
roads are called changes a bit firm by
firm they all have their own terminology
then the end is all the same right and
the business analyst role is the role
that you will have
fresh out of university if you leave a
university with a bachelor or master
degree
you just start out in consulting this is
the role that you will have of course
in this role you will usually crunch the
numbers conduct
interviews with clients create slight
decks so this is really the role where
you learn the ropes of the trait and for
this role in a country like germany you
can expect a salary
of roughly 70 000 euro per year for a
master level graduate which is of course
a very decent starting salary for a new
graduate you will have this business
analyst role for about two years
and after two years most of these tier
one firms offer something which is very
unique and this is the so-called
leaf program and here again how exactly
it's called difference a bit company by
company but what essentially it boils
down to is that the company will give
you the opportunity
to leave work again and to spend some
time to conduct a phd
or mba or often also social leave
year if you want to volunteer for a
social organization
and this time which usually takes two to
three years will be heavily
subsidized by your employer so for
instance if you do an mba the company
usually will sponsor a significant
portion of the tuition of your mba and
they will pay you money on top
often also up to a full salary just to
cover your living expenses in this time
and here even within the t1 firms there
can be significant differences in how
exactly this program
is set up how attractive it is and what
i learned now from talking to other
friends probably the mckinsey one is
arguably the most attractive then
followed by the boston consulting
followed by the bane and here also what
i want you to understand is that many of
these smaller tier 2 firms offer
programs like this
as well but then if you look into them
often they're not as attractive or maybe
they are saying yes you can do that but
in the end it turns out that only if
you're ranked
as one of the top top performers you
will really be offered to do this and
then the big majority of consultants in
the end will not have this opportunity
so i'd argue that this is really
something that on top of the regular
salary differences really sets apart
these p1 firms from these other firms
and you really should take this into
account when you compare the total
compensation package
in the first years of your time in
consulting because the value of the
compensation package that you get in
this leave
program can easily be in the six digits
so really have a look at this closely
before you ask yourself what company you
want to join after all then after the
leave usually you enter an
associate type of position this is also
the position that you will directly be
able to join
if you join consulting with an mba or
with a phd
in terms of the contents of your job
this is pretty much just an extension of
what you were doing
as a business analyst with the only
difference that now more is expected
from you so you will be now expected to
lead
larger parts of the project you will be
expected now to do things standalone
with very little guidance from your
project lead
just the workload the expectations the
responsibilities
you have will just increase will expand
compared to these other roads
and as an associate you can expect to
earn around 110
000 euro in germany again with
differences company by company so this
is indeed a significant salary increase
to the road that you had earlier then
this associate role is again something
that you will often do for about two
years or so
and then you advance and the project
lead role this is now the role where you
will be responsible for consulting teams
working on the ground and the client a
typical consulting team is the project
lead plus
one to four consultants so total team of
two to five consultants and then on top
of course you also have the junior
partners partners senior partners who
come on top will provide some guidance
and join you occasionally so as a
project lead you can expect to earn 140
to 150
000 euro base salary every year and then
at the project lead level
with many firms also the bonuses start
to increase so maybe you might have the
potential to earning up to
30 or even more bonus on top of your
base salary instead of maybe only 20
which was rather the norm for the lower
levels so this is now the first level
where also the compensation will vary
more significantly based on your
performance that you will bring to the
table in your job then after the project
lead role most firms distinguish
different levels of partner roads so
often it starts with a junior partner
level
which you will have for another two
years or so until then you can get
elected
partner of the firm this is now this
real full partner role which is often
the aspiration
of many many people then still want to
continue their career in consulting and
then after four to five years or so in
your partner role you can become a
senior partner which is then in terms of
job title
the highest level that you can reach so
when we discuss the salaries of these
different partner levels here it's
important to understand that these
salary structures are getting much more
complex so besides the base salary of
there's a component which is linked to
the performance of the company over roy
so how good is the
company doing overall that you're
working for this will affect your salary
and then also your performance element
so the bonus that you will get paid on
top of that
this will now pay an increasingly
important role of your overall
compensation but that being said as a
junior partner you can then expect to
earn
something about 200 to 250 000 euro
and then once you're really getting
elected a full partner this will usually
be above 300 000 euro in salary this
salary will then increase over time
again heavily also influenced by your
performance once you're a senior partner
this can then be rather around 600 to
800
000 euro and indeed the best earning
best performing senior partners
can earn in the millions so we'll earn
several million euro every year
of course while these figures sound very
high it's also important to understand
that it's not necessarily
easy to become partner there's a sole
concept an idea of the upper out
principle
if you never heard about that i willing
the video above here that i did on this
topic so in a nutshell
people will get filtered out many people
will get asked to leave the firm at some
point in their career only the very best
of course will have the opportunity to
become partner and then earn salaries in
these dimensions so now i'd be
interested to hear from you
is this surprising to you does this meet
your experiences and expectations
do you think these salaries are
extremely high or maybe not even that
high if you consider all the work that
goes into such a career
let me know your views in the comments
and as you know i will do my very best
to answer every single comment that you
write so if you took any value out of
this video at all
please hit the like button for the
youtube algorithm and also subscribe to
the channel and especially also turn on
the notification bell to stay up to date
on all my content if you want to see
even more from me also follow me on my
instagram my handle is from learning and
now as
always i also want to say thank you to
all the members of the channel you're
really making a difference a big
contribution to the work to the course
of this channel and if you are
interested in becoming a member as well
just click on the join button next to
the subscribe button to see how you can
support and also earn some member only
perks to all the rest of you
thank you for watching until the very
end i'm releasing new videos every
single
saturday and especially also next
saturday i have a very interesting video
planned for you so stay tuned
good weekend to all of you talk to you
next saturday this is heine from from
learning
bye-bye